alors gérer pourquoi être voilées sur
tmc alors c'est vrai que voilà on m'a
accusé d'avoir trahi ma famille d'avoir
trahi ma chaîne ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que mon retour sur ces huit ma
première prise de parole avait été
planifiée il était prévu que je fasse
donc ce émission de thierry ardisson le
samedi pour m'exprimer cette date a sans
cesse était décalée et au final eh bien
on m'a demandé d'aller m'exprimer
ailleurs puisque ces 8 avant de me
réintégrer voulait voir et bien c'est 8
apparemment enfin moi j'ai jamais eue
s'est dit au téléphone s'est vite ne m'a
jamais stipulé que si j'allais sur une
autre chaîne
j'étais viré note la production de
thierry ardisson m'a dit que ces huit
étaient d'accord et que ces 8 avant de
me remettre à l'antenne avait besoin de
voir un petit peu les retombées scala en
dire les gens lors de ma première prise
de parole et qu'il fallait que je prenne
la parole à york et vous avez pas la
terre ce moment là il ya aucune trahison
puisque moi vous vous doutez bien que si
j'avais pu faire mon retour chez thierry
non seulement je courais était quand
même beaucoup plus à l'aise et même des
fusils que ça arrive ça me fait plaisir
mais on m'a limite foutu en fait sur une
reddition savoir si c'était une mission
c'est pas une autre chaîne
ça pourrait être ici pas du tout on a la
vida york sur ces huit saigon voulait
pas que vous ne pouvez pas vous en à
marolles en fait de chanter pendant
n'était pas possible de vivre ou de la
production de tirer la récession est en
contact voilà alors si vous avez la
chaîne vous vous en rendrez que la
production vous a trahis de formation
j'en sais rien de ce qui s'est passé
réellement tout ce que je sais c'est
qu'il ya eu
comment dire une erreur de communication
interne
le message n'est pas passé on en a parlé
ce week-end au téléphone ces villes moi
comme je le redis je voulais m'exprimer
chez thierry ardisson
mais ça n'était pas plein voilà il ya
trahison il faut quand même préciser que
j'ai fait les choses quand même on va
dire proprement au nord
je le redis en obtenant une autorisation
écrite parce que mon compte à mon
contrat pardon m'interdisait de
m'exprimer dans une émission en frontal
avec celle de thierry ardisson le
dimanche à ce que je sache le jeudi je
n'ai donc pas fait concurrence
aujourd'hui les jaunards à celle de
thierry ardisson
moi je comprends tout à fait que vous
ayez voulu aller chez yann barthès parce
que ces deux types d'interviews
complètement différent que j'ai voulu et
ses gants mais c'est que je n'ai pas eu
le choix presse mais en tout cas cessé
rivé sur son chéri mais à ce moment là
pourquoi dès le départ de l'interview et
yann barthès vous disant en gros que
cyril a pété un cas dans la journée et
fait un peu mal hein juste pas compris
au québec ont fait je peux apprendre
dans une émission que je suis viré alors
qu'en fait c'est 8 ne m'a jamais stipulé
que j'avais interdiction d'aller hague
alors regardez regardez en plus on
m'encourageait la ior parce que vous
étiez sur ces 8 avec thierry ardisson on
avait entendu des menaces disant que si
vous exprimiez ailleurs vous auriez des
problèmes dont pro ici oui bah
d'ailleurs cyril hanouna fait une crise
de nerfs cet après midi j'ai envie de
l'égorger ah non mais moi je n'ai pas
appris est ce que je t'ai appelé non
mais j'ai eu des échos comme quoi
apparemment ça pose des problèmes que
j'avais trail vtt en colère et
d'ailleurs on en a parlé ce week-end tu
été vexé mais moi j'ai jamais voulu déjà
te trahir trahir la chaîne ou même que
tu prennes ça pour une attaque
personnelle
donc j'ai pas trop compris pourquoi tout
à coup je suis devenu la bête noire
pourquoi je me suis fait virer comme ça
on se dirait aller jouer à tous et
hayden barthez du pense pas une seconde
que ça m'a posé un problème c'est que la
nama attendait apparaît encore une fois
choisir je n'ai pas choisi juillet oui
voilà où vous envie d'aller dans cette
émission là vous en dit on m'a dit que
je suis libre de m'exprimer où je le
voulais quand j'ai effectivement proposé
cette émission parce qu'effectivement
cette émission avait contacté mon
avocate à plusieurs reprises
hamon m'a donné le feu vert pour égaler
au tir il a donné le feu vert
sa production est et donc mais de la
production de petits radis sont alors
moi j'ai eu ce tir ardisson juge
stéphane simon le producteur il m'a dit
qu'en fait il vous a donné l'
autorisation
parce que étant donné que ces huit ne
répondait pas à leurs appels et que vous
reveniez pas l'antenne
ils l'ont dit ils vous ont dit écoute
fais ce que tu veux vas-y mais voilà va
sur une autre émission
enfin alors j'étire ardisson qui me dit
tu iras 10 on voit là qui m'envoie un
sms qui me dit les patrons de ces huit
ne voulais pas le revoir sur s'est vite
quelles que soient les missions donc ni
té pmp accord ni william les maires
son amie keira redit son chéri qui me
donne les infos en direct voilà donc
encore une fois il n'ya pas de trahison
me faire lapider 1 / sur la place
publique parce que j'ai travaillé la
famille non j'étais le premier demande
or justement pour venir mais s'il y met
effectivement dus sur les 8 ou seriez
venu ici si la chaîne vous avez dit bien
sûr mais aussi parce que c'est vous qui
m'avez demandé de venir dans un verre
mais les primes et il faut que je fasse
un passage par là il y avait tout un
plan de com est donc lâché mon pour
réintégrer la chaîne il était prévu que
je viens dans cette émission
donc il n'y avait rien de personnel
encore il nous en comprend pas c'est au
poil attirer les médias redit sion qui
radient son but dit maxime saada ne
voulais pas le revoir sur ces huit maxi
ça là c'est le grand big boss lorsque je
ne tiens pas toujours et dans un premier
temps on vous a dit il ya un plan de
communication et vous ferez votre vos
réapparition sur tpm puis dans un
deuxième temps dans un second temps on
vous dira on vous donne plus
d'informations et on vous dit vous
pouvez aller sur tmc et comptait déjà
vérifié j'avais la réponse à cette
question ma foi je lancerai ma foi
comment dire tout oui mais non je l'est
pas